Okay.
It is time for one of the most popular segments
that we do with a very small section of the
audience.
A lot of people do not care about the segment,
but the people that like it really like it
and were furious when it went away, so we
brought it back every three or four weeks.
I will recommend some books to you that I've
read.
Some will be fiction, some will be nonfiction.
All of my recommendations from this week and
previous weeks are at David pakman.com/recommendations
if you use the links on that page to buy any
of these books, we get a little slice to quote
Andrew Yang of, uh, your Amazon transaction.
So please do that.
Check it out.
I've got a whole bunch of great stuff.
Recommended David pakman.com/recommendations
today.
It is a big week for recommendations.
I will have two nonfiction books to begin
with.
And then two fiction books.
First nonfiction book, billion dollar whale
by Tom Wright and Bradley hope this is a fascinating
caper.
I've got my Harvard co-op bookstore, um, a
bookmark in.
They're still very Boston centric, extraordinary.
Um, this is a really great Kapor about a Malaysian
guy named Joe lo who did a combination of
some really bad things and some really entrepreneurial
things, which is often the case, uh, in, in
many other circumstances as well.
Um, and this is the story of how he built
relationships, how he got into the business
world and ultimately how he took advantage
of a lot of different people.
I don't want to say too much because really
if you don't know the story, it is interesting
to learn about it as you read the book could
not recommend this more highly.
It is certainly a page Turner.
It's not short.
It's 400 pages.
But I found that it really went by quickly
because you, it just sucks you in and you
want to read it.
If you like books such as, um, uh, wrote the
Jones town about Jim Jones or the book about
that.
I recommend that a few weeks ago about how
they found a Ross Ulbricht, the creator of
the dark web, uh, the silk road, rather if
you like books like blow about a drug dealer,
drug traffic or George Junge.
If that genre is interesting to you, then
you will really like this book.
Okay.
Billion dollar whale, Tom Wright and Bradley
hope highly recommended.
Okay.
I think I might've mentioned this book in
passing before.
I don't remember how I came across this.
It's called consider the fork a history of
how we cook and eat by B Wilson.
Now you might think, who cares how they first
made the first tablespoon?
That is not what this book is about.
This book, it's a lot of sociology about the
ways in which having containers for food,
like having a bowl.
What would nutrition and cuisine be like if
we didn't even have bowls or utensils?
Oh, what changed when fire was first used
to cook food and what was the effect on people's
bodies and people's teeth?
Really interesting stuff about, uh, how people's
teeth changed once we no longer ate food by
sort of taking a hunk of something biting
down and using a knife to cut a piece off
that significantly changed, uh, people's teeth.
It's very, very interesting book.
I guess I'd call it a combination sort of
like science, sociology, history and I guess
it's sort of as a cooking book as well.
In in some strict sense, the book is considered
the fork a history of how we cook and eat
by B Wilson.
Don't miss this one a and now two fiction
recommendations.
I actually read this book in English, although
because that's just what someone handed to
me, although I'm told that in Spanish.
It is, it is delightful.
This is the club do Mohs by our tutor Paris
Roberto who is a Spanish author.
This is a sort of caper that pulls in real
historical stuff about the author of the count
of Monte Cristo Alexander Dumas, uh, combined
with a caper about a, a book dealer and antique
book, a trader investigator type of guy.
And it weaves a very compelling narrative
and I think it is a, so the, the cover says
that it's a cross between echo and Anne rice.
I've never read Anne rice.
I have read Humberto echo and there are definitely
uh, there's a feel that is similar to elements
of Humberto echo in this.
So check that out.
The club Dumas's are [inaudible] Paris.
Roberta is the author.
And lastly, this is someone we've interviewed
on the program.
Blake crouches book, dark matter.
I've read a bunch of stuff by Blake crouch.
I think there's a TV series written by him
or based on his writing called good behavior
or bad behavior.
I don't remember exactly.
I've read the book, but this is a, one of
his newer books, not his newest.
It is dark in a lot of ways.
Uh, it just so happens the name of the book
is dark matter, but it is dark in ways.
I've let a few friends borrow this and everybody
is quite taken with it.
It is once again, a major, major page Turner.
I would be shocked if you can put this book
down.
I know that if you have Don Jr's new book,
then you might be focusing on that instead
of other things, but I recommend this instead
a dark matter by Blake crouch.
All of these recommendations available for
free.
The recommendations, you might have to buy
the books at David pakman.com/recommendations
and remember if you use any of the links on
that page to buy these books.
Oh, we get a little bit of a cut off of a,
the cost of the books.